الفنانه هند ياسين هند يسعد صباحك اهلا بك
شكرا على تواجدك معنا في صباح العربيه
ومبارك عليك الفوز بهذه الجائزه القيمه من
ورد كافضل وجه مفضل تعال فئه المسلسلات
تفضلي هنبدا شعورك بهذا الفوز كبير
يسعد صباحك اول شيء انا سعيده بتواجد معكم
والله يبارك فيك يا رب
شعوري بهذا الفوز كان همم
رهيب كده مختلف ااه
مختلط بين الخوف بين الحماس بين الفرحه
بين بين كثير
الف مبروك
فماذا تريد هيلدا من المستقبل الدرامي
واعمالها الدراميه مستقبله
ان شاء الله باذن الله هل ده شخص مره طموح
وكل
نقطه او كل انجازي سوي او كل شيء يحققه
يشوفها انه هو نقطه البدايه
بنفس الوقت الحمد لله انه اليوم عندنا
اليوم الحمد لله عندنا دوله قاعده تدعم
المواهب بشكل يعني جدا كبير وزي ما شفنا
في السنوات الاخيره همم كيف انه في مواهب
شابه جدا مميزه وجميله ولله الحمد وهذا
كله من حرص القاده ومن حرص المسؤولين
ودعهم ولله الحمد
وهذا الشيء يخليني انا فخوره
جدا ويخليني انجز اكثر